[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace mucho tiempo cuando tenía 23 años
estaba caminando la calle y de pronto me
topé a una ex
esta ex tenía mucho tiempo de no verla
tenía como dos años de no verla y me dio
muchísimo gusto verla empezamos con lo
clásico que padre verte no sé qué y me
ofreció algo bastante chido me dijo way
si tienes tiempo porque no vamos si nos
tomamos un cafecito
en cámara puede funcionar esto nos
fuimos nos sentamos y la plática
prometía demasiado porque pues eran dos
años de no verla entonces iban a ver
muchísimos temas
nos sentamos y luego luego ella empezó a
platicar me empezó a decir que se había
comprado la camioneta de sus sueños me
enseñó fotos en fin me empezó a contar
muchísimas cosas nuevas de lo que estaba
pasando en su vida y llegó mi turno y me
hizo una pregunta cotidiana muy sencilla
al parecer
y me pregunto y tú qué has hecho para lo
que casi esté intuitivamente contesté
nada ya sabes todo igual y hay veces que
no escuchamos lo que decimos pero esta
vez esta respuesta sí la escuché y si me
que generó un gran impacto porque neta
todo seguía igual habían pasado dos años
y no tenía absolutamente nada que
contarle no tenía amigos nuevos tenía
mismo de para el mismo carro no había
emprendido absolutamente nada no tenía
algún proyecto diferente
neta no había hecho absolutamente nada
con mi vida en esos dos años
entonces evidentemente la plática no
duró muchísimo más nos despedimos se fue
a mi casa y me puse a pensar lo que
había sucedido no el impacto que había
causado ese momento en mi vida porque
neta mi vida se había paralizado había
perdido de alguna forma el rumbo neta no
estaba pasando nada y más con mi
personalidad yo siempre ha sido una
persona que le encanta estar activo que
le encanta comerse al mundo que siempre
busca cosas nuevas nuevos platillos está
abierto a nuevos sabores a muchísimas
cosas pero realmente en esos dos años no
había hecho nada
entonces con esto decidí prometerme algo
que no me prometo tampoco muchas cosas
porque no me gusta ser tan duro conmigo
mismo pero esto era esencial que me lo
tenía que prometer para el resto de mi
vida y fue que ante una pregunta así de
una persona que no había visto y que me
preguntará y tú qué has hecho no me iba
a volver a quedar callado y siempre iba
a tener algo nuevo que contarle a esa
persona
pero mucha gente dice no prometas algo
que no vas a cumplir yo a eso le
agregaría no prometas algo que no vas a
intentar cumplir que no vas a hacer
cosas para cumplirlo entonces pues me
tenía que empezar a aplicar y tenía que
empezar a hacer cosas para que esto esto
sucediera tenía que de alguna forma
activar mi presente y fue muy extraño
porque para activar mi presente y tener
un mejor futuro necesariamente tenía que
regresar al pasado
tenía que saber que quería entonces
empecé a hacer un trabajo de hecho justo
en ese momento me di cuenta que perdí
muchísimas cosas sobre todo perdí
la actividad de la escritura y me
gustaba mucho escribir cuentos escribió
muchísimas cosas y había dejado de
hacerlo entonces dije va perfecto la
parte no soy muy tecnológico entonces
también funciona mucho pluma y papel
hoy me puse a escribir y empecé por
justo qué quieres qué era lo que a ti te
gustaba en esta parte de regresar al
pasado voltea a ver a ese eduardito
pequeño y fue como preguntarle güey que
te gustaba que era lo que te movía
cuáles eran tus sueños que era eso que
te hacía feliz que activaba tu vida y
empecé a darle muchísimas vueltas
y también hice un trabajo
interior porque en esta pausa de estos
dos años evidentemente las fortalezas
que tenía de personalidad pues se habían
reducido y las debilidades o los puntos
malos emocionales que podría tener
habían crecido entonces necesariamente
tenía que volver a hacer ese análisis
esa introspección de saber qué es lo que
había cambiado con mi vida
emocionalmente para volver a
reestructurarla
me acuerdo que en esa época una persona
me recomendó algo bastante cool y me
dijo way porque no haces una lista de 50
cosas que quisieras hacer
y dije la zona bien pero 50 cosas
en ese momento que pueda pensar y dije
way ahorita no tengo cinco de dónde voy
a sacar 50 cosas que quiero hacer
y el trabajo si les puedo recomendar eso
háganlo es increíble este ejercicio
porque neta te obliga a eso te obliga a
irle a rascar a lo que está más adentro
de ti a profundizar contigo y encuentras
muchísimas cosas y se vale cualquier
cosa se vale poner esos sueños que
piensas que son medio tontos o esos
sueños que piensas que son imposibles yo
en la lista puse cosas como aprender
italiano
bailar salsa aprender a bailar salsa soy
muy malo tengo dos pies izquierdos
también puede tener cuadritos algún día
que ahí vamos ahí vamos y puse cosas más
sustanciales como aprender meterme a
estudiar psicología
escribir un libro escribir una muy buena
canción para mandar un mensaje al mundo
o ir a un partido de roger federer en
wimbledon o ser dt de algún equipo de
fútbol pues de cosas más
sueños que podrían ser un poquito más
lejanos
al hacer esto pasa algo que con tu
cerebro y con todo tu ser al traer a la
conciencia tus sueños inmediatamente se
activa y empieza a tu cerebro a buscar
esa línea para poder llegar a tus sueños
y no la parte está necesariamente de la
ley de atracción que increíble funciona
pero esto es algo real o sea las cosas
que están en tu inconsciente si las
traes a tu consciente va a ser más fácil
que las puedas lograr pero para lograr
tus sueños existe también algo
fundamental que es que los tienes que
justificar tienes que argumentar que
realmente eso es lo que quieres mi
manera de ver la justificación es que
tienes que encontrar ese motivo extra
tienes que encontrar ese punto de fe o
eso que literal es un empujoncito ese
empujón que necesitas para ir por tus
sueños esto se encuentra creo otra vez
haciendo un trabajo de introspección ir
a tu corazón realmente y sacar desde tu
corazón
la razón correcta de por qué quieres
esto realmente lo quiero porque hay
muchos sueños fugaces de repente nos nos
pasa que estás viendo una película y el
actor o la actriz es son muy buenos lo
están haciendo muy bien y dices claro
ahí está perfecto ya voy a abandonar
todo siempre quise ser actor entonces
vamos a abandonar o te vas a un show de
stand up comedy y dices wow eso era a
partir yo soy súper chistoso 100% puedo
hacer esto y no esos sueños son fugaces
o tal vez pueden funcionar pero tienes
que ir a argumentar los por ejemplo en
la lista yo puse estudiar lo de
psicología
perfecto es un sueño pero en el trabajo
de argumentación me di cuenta que desde
chiquito es algo que estaba 100% en mi
yo empecé a estudiar psicología a los 26
años entonces tuve mucho tiempo para
documentar esto y darme cuenta que yo
soy una persona que le encanta escuchar
a los demás
le encanta tratar de mandar un mensaje
de motivación y algún apoyo a mis amigos
a mi familia a la gente cercana al
mesero que me está atendiendo siempre
trato de que su mundo o su vida su
momento sea un poquito mejor
aparte de que me gusta tratar de hacer
las cosas bien y pues evidentemente para
poder saber cómo desfragmentar la
problemática o la situación de alguna
persona pues tenía que estudiarlo y
saberlo de manera científica no nada más
hacer las cosas al aventón entonces
tenía todo muy bien argumentado y por
eso decidí estudiar psicología en esta
parte de la justificación
cabe mucho hacer como una jerarquía de
tus sueños que pongas como una lista y
que pongas un cierto orden porque
definitivamente no está en el mismo
nivel aprender a bailar salsa que
estudiar psicología ya tienen un orden y
está esta jerarquía que hace sirve para
que te des cuenta que la forma de llegar
a tu sueño a veces no es lineal no solo
hay una forma de llegar ahí porque si
consigues una cosa es muy chistoso pero
esa te puede ayudar para ir al otro lado
y después si ya estás en este lado estas
dos te pueden ayudar para conseguir el
otro sueño que estaba en tu lista
entonces te das cuenta que hay una línea
en esta parte de buscar cómo llegar a tu
sueño el siguiente como paso que yo
siento que es fundamental es buscar
todas tus opciones porque ya sabes que
quieres ya sabes por qué lo quieres ya
lo superar con metas te estás muy seguro
ahora hay que buscar cómo vas a llegar a
ese sueño y en esta parte siento que hay
que ser súper creativos no hay que
tenerle miedo a nada no hay que pensar
no esta opción no no es tan justo no me
va a llevar porque tal empieza a ser un
poco negativo creo que en esta parte hay
que dejar la negatividad y hay que
tratar de ser optimistas y cualquier
opción es buena de hecho no hay que
cerrar las puertas está practicando este
punto con una persona y me contó que
había que un día se le olvidó su mochila
en un cajero automático y que se acordó
hasta que llegó a su casa después de
viajar en el metro y mi primera pregunta
fue de y regresaste a ver si estaba
mejor no no obviamente ya no iba a estar
quién sabe no elimines ninguna opción tú
regresa y vamos a ver si está tal vez si
es mínima la posibilidad pero no
elimines ninguna opción no te cierres
ninguna puerta en lo de mis sueños puse
ver a roger federer jugar en wimbledon
de alguna vez roger federer es un
tenista y wimbledon es un espacio como
muy exclusivo es como la catedral del
tenis y es difícil entrar a los boletos
son muy caros y es algo complicado pero
yo sabía que era parte de mis sueños ya
había hecho todos los pasos anteriores y
entonces empecé a buscar cuáles eran mis
opciones para ver a roger federer en
wimbledon y descubrí qué
podía usar bueno pensé dije todos los
estadios hay reventa entonces voy a ir
al estadio y tal vez haya reventa o en
esa época tenía una credencial de prensa
y dije voy a mandar un mail para ver si
puedo sacar una acreditación de prensa y
con eso entrará a ver a roger o también
dije por qué no qué tal que hay una
puerta y medio abierta una barda y medio
chiquita hoy me salto me paso también lo
también lo pensé y la última que
encontré fue que hay un camping una
puede ser camping una noche anterior y
eres como acreedor un boleto
todo esto también lo logré porque en el
trabajo de buscar tus opciones tienes
que volverte una hormiguita de
laboratorio o de biblioteca no sé dónde
la hormiguita pero tienes que clavar te
y tienes que buscar todas las
posibilidades que están tienes que
investigar muchísimo a ver qué camino
puede ser apus esto a mí a conozco a
alguien a buscar todo buscar todo lo que
está alrededor de tus sueños
ya sabes que quieres
ya sabes por qué lo quieres ya están
todas tus opciones y ahora toca el
momento más bonito que es en sus marcas
listos fuera nunca había puesto tanta
atención a esa frase que todos hemos
escuchado hasta que desarrolle esta
plática
y es que si te pones a pensar no hay
ningún nadador piloto
corredor que por ejemplo no está usain
bolt así no la línea de inicio como
haciendo se baje ahí esperando a que
desde el pistolazo inicial y sale
corriendo no está en sus marcas
está ahí preparado y para este punto tú
ya estás listo tú ya estás preparado ya
tienes muchísimas cosas atrás ya tienes
muchísima
muchísima investigación en la cual
tienes que confiar si es el caso del
deportista el deportista tiene
disciplina tiene entrega tiene
muchísimos sacrificios tienen muchísimos
días de entrenamiento que hizo previo
para estar ahí en sus marcas listos
ahora toca justo eso arriesgarte tomar
acción e ir por tus sueños muchas
personas no se arriesgan a hacer eso
porque tienen miedo pero volviendo a lo
mismo usain bolt no está ahí en sus
marcas listos pensando tengo miedo a no
lograrlo tengo miedo a no llegar a en
primer lugar que va a decir la gente que
está en el estadio que va a decir mi
familia si no si no logro esto que no
está pensando en todas esas cosas él
tiene muy claro que quiere llegar en
primer lugar y hacer ese 958 y ser el
corredor más rápido de la historia
en cuanto a lo de federer
yo ya estaba listo yo estaba preparado y
dije perfecto
ahora toca arriesgarme y ahora toca ir
por ese sueño entonces fui al estadio
como le decía es algo muy exclusivo y
evidentemente no había reventa todos
estaban en traje y no había
absolutamente nada de esa posibilidad
el mail este de prensa nunca me lo
contestaron obvio no había una puerta
entreabierta no me pude saltar ni me
pude clavar en wimbledon y la opción que
fue viable fue lo del camping y después
de muchos otros pasos acabé cumpliendo
mi sueño de ver a roger federer
ahora
yo no tuve miedo justo en ese momento yo
no tenía miedo yo no estaba en el 'news
tal así y diciendo tengo miedo de ir a
hacer todo esto y no lograr entrar al
estadio y ver a roger federer si si en
algún momento existe un miedo en mí fue
el miedo a no intentarlo
en haberme quedado en el hostal pensando
y con pena y con miedos y con qué dirán
o peor aún haberme quedado en mexico y
verlo desde la tele y decir chalé yo
pude haber intentado ir a ver a roger
federer
ahora yo siempre digo que la vida es un
misterio porque puedes estar muy
preparado puedes saber que quieres
puedes saber por qué lo quieres puedes
ver todas tus opciones y hay veces que
las cosas no se logran nadie puede
asegurar que va a suceder algo no
podemos controlar el futuro otra cosa
que hay que aprender es que los sueños
evolucionan y lo que pensaste una vez
cuando era chiquito no necesariamente lo
que sigues queriendo hay que saber que
la vida evoluciona evoluciona tu lado' y
hay muchísimos cambios que van a ir
sucediendo por ejemplo
a los 12 años de secundaria el maestro
dejó la clásica tarea de bueno mañana
quiero que nos digan me digan cómo se
ven cuando sean grandes
y lo primero que puse fue siendo
futbolista para mí el fútbol es lo que
más amo y dije voy a ser futbolista
cuando sea grande desde chiquito siempre
he pensado en que quiero tener una
familia que quiero encontrar a una mujer
increíble con la cual compartir mi vida
tener dos hijos y compartir mi vida
justo con ella
tener una casa propia tener un negocio
propio tener un bulldog y ser feliz
tenía esos sueños y puse eso en esa
lista de cuando me veía grande y ahora
tengo 31 años y no juego fútbol y no voy
a jugar fútbol de mi vida
no tengo esposa soy soltero no tengo dos
hijos no tengo negocio propio no tengo
casa propia
yo tengo un bulldog de hecho ni siquiera
me gustan los bulldogs ahora preferiría
un golden entonces soy muy feliz
y sé que las cosas cambian y te tienes
que adaptar a esos cambios
por último
yo estoy aquí para decirles que no sean
como ese yo de 23 años no pierdan dos
años de su vida no pierdan su tiempo ese
tiempo que yo perdí en esos dos años no
va a regresar jamás hay que aprender a
vivir el presente no sean tampoco esa
persona que te dice tranquilo wey hay
más tiempo que vida es de las frases que
más me hacen enojar porque no tu tiempo
dura lo que tu vida te deja va a seguir
el tiempo aquí en la tierra sí pero tú
ya estás muerto ya no tiene chance de
hacer absolutamente nada entonces hay
que empezar a hacer cosas hay que vivir
el presente si estás con un amigo o con
alguna persona voy a sonar a mamá pero
deja el celular y darle todo el tiempo
esa persona dedícale 100% el valor del
tiempo a él porque no sabes justo si te
vas a morir se va a morir o lo vas a
volver a ver en tu vida si vas a dormir
échate la mejor jeta si vas a hacer un
trabajo hace el mejor trabajo que puedas
a mí una vez
me cambiaron la vida con una pregunta y
ahora yo estoy aquí en frente de ustedes
para preguntarles y tú qué estás
haciendo gracias
[Aplausos]